in this work we take on the challenging
task of learning to synthesize speech
from normalized text or phonemes in an
intimate manner resulting in models
which operate directly on character or
phoneme input sequences and produce raw
speech audio outputs okay that wasn't
the real model I just thought it sounded
really funny this is a text-to-speech
model and it actually sounds like this
in this work we take on the challenging
task of learning to synthesized speech
from normalized text or phonemes in an
end-to-end manner resulting in models
which operate directly on character or
phoneme input sequences and produce raw
speech audio outputs okay now you've
probably if you have listened to the
text and not just how the text sounds
you have gotten what this paper is about
so the paper is called end to end
adversarial text-to-speech by Jeff Donna
Wade sander Dillman Michael I Binkowski
Erik Ellison and Karen Simonian of I
believe of mostly deep mind and this
paper on a high level it produces speech
so sound the sound waves of speech
directly from text or from what they
call normalized text or phoneme text and
it does so without any intermediate
supervised drede presentations and
that's a challenging task and the main
problems here are the alignment problem
that they have to solve and actually
making making this work in an
adversarial manner so we're going to
look at this paper as always if you like
work like this consider subscribing and
sharing it out and if you have any
comments leave them in the comment
section ok so what's the problem with
text-to-speech text-to-speech is
basically you take a piece of text like
this one modern text to speech synthesis
pipelines typically involve blah blah
blah and you want to make a model that
takes this and outputs sound waves as if
a human would say it right so he's
they're modern
text-to-speech and so on now have
multiple problems when doing this first
of all the text here is words let's say
we can tokenize the text into words so
you have modern text-to-speech those are
four tokens
however sound waves are of course much
much densely sampled so these sound
waves they are typically in the order of
something like 24 kilohertz sampled so
that's the the ratio of one token to
output samples is super high so one
token will produce many many thousand
samples in the speech so that's the
first problem
the second problem is that if you have
training data so you have data that has
a piece of text and you have the sound
wave that a human you know the human
read that particular piece of text you
still don't know which word exactly
corresponds to which portion of that
text you simply know the entire text
corresponds to the entire sound wave you
don't know this word text right here you
don't know you don't know where where it
starts and where it ends in this sound
wave and the the last problem you
obviously have is that you want to make
this in a way that it generalizes that
it sounds like a human but also
generalizes to some other text and this
paper here solves all of these problems
jointly by doing an adversarial approach
to learning and it does it end to end
now adversarial simply means that you
have a generator that takes in the piece
of text right here and generates this
sound wave and then you have a
discriminator that looks at this sound
wave and it looks at the real sound wave
so they're the real okay
the real saw so let's say this over here
is real and this is what the generator
has produced the discriminator tries to
discriminate between the two now this is
not entirely the same thing as
a as a supervised loss usually in a gang
you do not have the corresponding
samples ready to be simply you simply
input a real sample here and the
generator produces a generated sample
here you do not necessarily have in a
classic gang the corresponding sample
here you assume that you have the
corresponding real sample but it's still
different than supervised learning in
that both go through a discriminator and
the discriminator tries to tell this
criminais trees a neural network tries
to tell which one is real and which one
is generated in fact the discriminator
is a set of neural networks they were
going to go into that shortly
so it's adversarial in the sense that
there is a generator and a discriminator
and it is end to end in the sense that
usually what these pipelines do is they
take the text and we've looked at this
for example in the video about this
facebook's text-to-speech system so they
take the text and the first thing they
do is they would produce a set of of
whatever they would call features like
textual features called textual features
so these are these are sort of
intermediate features for the text to be
produced and then another model would
take these and it would produce
something like spectrograms spec
programs and then another model would
take the spectrograms and finally
produce sound or speech so you have
usually in these systems you have
intermediate representation and each of
these models right here can be trained
by itself so that's an advantage that
you can train for example you can train
a model that goes from a spectrogram to
a Soundwave by itself and you don't need
you simply need sound for that the
computation from sound to spectrogram is
super easy so you can generate your own
training data so you can go from
spectrogram to
and you can train a model like this so
in these pipelines usually there are
multiple stages and each of these models
has to be trained by itself this paper
tries to do this end to end that means
you input the text and you get out the
you get out the Soundwave and and there
is nothing in between
that the I mean of course there are
latent representations but you terrain
it ends to end in one go okay so let's
look at the different systems they
employ first of all let's look at the
discriminators because that's the
easiest so they have these
discriminators and these are adopted
from this Gantt ets paper now as we
already set the discriminator try to to
differentiate between real and fake
sound and they do it in a sort of so if
they were to just look at the entire
sound wave then it would just basically
reduce to comparing the two
but instead the discriminators they
operate on very small windows so in
specific they have five different
discriminators and each of the five
different discriminators take a
different sized window length but all of
these windows are super short
so one discriminator might take this
long windows another discriminator might
take a bit longer windows and another
discriminator might take a bit shorter
windows and that of course from the real
end from the fake and the discriminators
simply try to discriminate only in these
windows whether it's real or fake and
now we're a bit more into the Gann
setting where you know you simply have
one data point of the real and one data
point of the fake and you have to
compare them and this here I believe is
one of the keys why this model
generalizes because the discriminators
basically they try to assess whether a
short sequence sounds like real or
sounds like fake and whether the the two
samples sound alike in different scales
of time and by only doing this on these
short scale
you can you can the loss sort of
generalizes otherwise if you compare it
on the entire Soundwave it would just
reduce to comparing point like point by
point right here and if the generator
produces something that's not exactly
aligned then of course every point would
be wrong and you'd run into all sorts of
questions so this is a set of five
discriminators that all try to take each
takes a different length of sub sub
sound of this wave tries to discriminate
real from fake
that's the discriminator loss they have
an additional discriminator loss where
they compute spectrograms of these
things so spectrograms and compute
spectrogram of this and they have a
discriminator another neural network
here that it tries to distinguish which
one is real and which one is fake note
that this is not the same as down here
where the spectrogram is an intermediate
representation here the sound is the
output and from the sound you compute
the spectrogram and then you compare the
two so this is simply a different the
spectrogram is a different feature space
for the discriminator to compute the
loss it is not an intermediate
representation on the way to produce the
sound itself so that the difference
that's the difference here between the
classic approach and this approach so
it's end-to-end adversarial so we got
the discriminator the discriminators
simply try to differentiate the sound
waves and short scales as well as the
spectrograms
now the second part is of course the
generator how do we even produce sound
and that's this diagram right here so
you have this Gann TTS generator this is
a generator that takes in a it takes in
a hidden representation so it takes in
tokens let's say token one token to
let's go from the from the one before
think of a sentence hello there
okay so it takes these tokens and of
course it takes like hidden
representations of the tokens and it
would output it will output for each one
or for this joint sequence one hidden
two it would output the sound wave okay
and this has been a paper before this
game TTS and you also you condition it
on the speaker and on latent variables
like how you want the pitch to be and so
on that's not really important for us
right here the generator can simply take
these token embeddings and produce sound
the problem is in the original paper you
had an alignment you knew which token
corresponded to which piece of sound and
therefore you sort of knew so after that
you need to compare this to the
generator thing and you knew which token
correspond to which piece of sound right
here so the generator knew what it had
to produce from each token how long it
should be and so on so this is the
generally the alignment problem or what
I call the alignment problem so if you
take a piece of text like this entire
paragraph right here let's look at this
paragraph this paragraph to read it out
takes like 30 to 60 seconds you can't
train really models that output this
long of sound it it would be it would be
too big of a sample you want to Train
ideally on segments they train segments
that are I believe here two second
windows from each examples so because
they say if we train on 22nd that would
just be wasteful and prohibitively
expensive now the problem of course is
if I simply take a window here like this
one of two seconds and I have my human
that has read this entire paragraph in
one go I have no clue again which which
a part of the entire Soundwave of this
paragraph these this subsequence
corresponds to
a good guess would be to go like well
this is about 50% in so maybe here to
here maybe who knows ok and even within
that and that's what we discussed before
you have no clue how long this word here
is going to take up within this piece of
sound and that's the general alignment
problem right here
so in this entire sound wave where is
the piece and how do these words
distribute across the wave of sound the
original model had as I understand it
such alignments and therefore this
generator could work really well because
you had these alignments without these
alignments it doesn't work as well and
you can on their website that I've shown
you initially you can listen to samples
where they disable each of these things
so this generator is really good at
producing sound when it has these
alignments so the challenging task here
is how do you compute these alignments
how do you compute this thing if you
don't have it if you have if you don't
have it in your training data so it
needs to be part of the loss so that's
what this entire architecture down here
is alright so the text is down here it
goes in and the first thing they do is
they normalize the text and they
transform it into phonemes which is you
can do this in a deterministic fashion
there are scripts that do this this is
the only pre-processing they do and they
can also leave it away in the Haven
ablation on their website so this is
like phoneme text cat sat on the mat now
this phoneme text goes through this big
block of convolutions and of dilated
convolutions and this outputs a 200
Hertz representation token length
alignment okay I should specify this so
for each token here it outputs a length
so this thing predicts the length of
each of the tokens these all of this all
of this thing here is
- to embed the tokens in hidden space
and then predict its length you can see
that right here okay so first we use f2
to take X so f is a stack of dilated
convolutions and it takes X and outputs
a hidden representation so H so first X
goes to H and then H is used to predict
L and L is the length of that token so
we embed this into a hidden
representation with this right here and
then we use this stack to predict the
length of each token so this could be
this could say something like this cat
token right here is 20 milliseconds long
or instead of milliseconds you would use
something like frames or data points
maybe this is 200 data points long and
then sat is a bit shorter so this is 100
long and on is really short so this is
50 long so for each token it predicts
the length all right so now if we have
the length of each we can sort of
calculate where the starting point is so
if we want to know if we know that here
is the beginning and the beginning of
the sentence we conservatively assume
that there is um so they give some
silence buffer here but roughly you can
assume that the beginning of the speech
corresponds to the first the first token
right you can simply trace the waveform
and whenever it goes that's where the
first token starts so then if since we
know that's where the first token starts
and if we could predict the length of
each one correctly we could simply sum
those up to figure out where our it
starts so if we want to know where on
starts we simply go from the beginning
and go 200 plus 100 milliseconds so or
data points 200 plus 1
here is where on starts okay and if we
want to figure out the middle of on we
simply add the half of this number so
plus 25 gets you to the middle so this
is this here is the center of the token
on
so for each token we predict a length
like this and thereby we can just
calculate for each one by summing up
from the beginning and then adding half
of its own length where the center of
that token in the entire sequences and
now we do this we said we take random to
second audio but we do this procedure
for the entire for the entire text okay
for the for every single token in the
text that we look at in the twenty
second text we do this because then for
each token we'll get a token Center and
now the aligners job here is to align
that to the actual sound so what we also
give the generator is here the offset so
let's say we have this twenty second of
speech and we randomly sample these two
seconds and that's maybe five seconds
from the beginning we also tell it this
is five seconds right here so what we
can now do is we can calculate back sort
of and say okay here I have I first need
to discard five seconds of my signal and
I have a prediction how long each token
is so I can just cross out tokens until
I have basically wasted five seconds and
then I know okay from here to wherever
these things sum up to two seconds from
here to that those are my two seconds
that I want to look at now this is how I
figure out where in the big sound wave
my fragment is right because I have this
offset
where I sampled it and I simply add use
this and the predicted lengths to figure
it out now I still need to figure out
these tokens that are actually in the
span how do they distribute and that's
what this aligner here does since we've
already predicted the token centers we
simply assume that if these are correct
right then if this is let's say if this
is one second long I assume that the
middle is after 0.5 seconds or this is
one second the middle is 0.5 seconds so
I think that this token is aligned right
here this is the center of the token now
we want to be a little bit a little bit
fuzzy with respect to that so what they
do is they sort of use a Gaussian kernel
right here so for each token as you can
see here each token has a center which
is here so the y-axis is the time in
sound and the x-axis is the token and
for each token we say well it doesn't
have to be exactly there it can be so
they put a Gaussian kernel like this
okay if you imagine this kernel popping
out of the frame
they say this is about where the center
is and for this token right for this
token right here they say well it's it's
probably here in the middle but it could
also be here or here or here or here and
we wait this like this so these are
these are the weights and then you
simply sum up the weights with these
embeddings so for each token out of this
style a the convolution block you get a
hidden embedding and by using this
alignment matrix that you computed by
predicting the lengths and therefore
predicting the Centers of the tokens you
can then sort of shift so first you
assume that H 1 H 2 H 3 if you were to
do nothing
these would just all take up like a
third of the time and now by multiplying
with this matrix you have the
opportunity because you pretty
did a longer length for the first token
you have the opportunity to shift that a
bit to the right and maybe shorten the
second token a bit and then the third
token goes until the end okay that
that's what this aligner thing is this
is not a model by itself all that this
takes in is the computation right here
of the token lengths this estimates
these token lengths for each of the
tokens and the rest is deterministic
it's simply saying okay how much is the
offset cool that's how we know we're in
the sound wave we are and then where is
each of the centers and we simply do
that by summing up the predicted token
lengths and then we use a Gaussian
kernel with like a set hyper parameter
to be a little bit fuzzy with respect to
these lengths right here so to be
differentiable basically and that will
that will ultimately train this loss
this model right here that computes the
token lengths right so we sum up in a
weighted fashion these embeddings right
here and that's what goes into the
generator so now we have embeddings and
we have the alignments for the
embeddings which are these pieces of
we're in the sound wave these are and
from that the generator can now produce
the sound wave itself okay and that's
basically that's just an example in here
I think that's just an up convolution up
sampling from 200 Hertz signal to a 24
kilohertz signal cool so that's that now
they discover this doesn't work and why
doesn't it work it's because at the
beginning of training these token length
predictions here are pretty crappy and
so that means that I guess especially
this part even where you say well we're
we're in the sound wave of my 20 seconds
do I even need to cut out to compare
with the discriminator right if you give
if you
sample this piece here and that's what
you give to the discriminator but your
length predictions are so far off that
the generator is trying to produce this
particular piece because it thinks it
thinks Oh instead of producing this
tokens here which is what the
discriminator looks at it produces these
tokens here of course you have no no
chance no matter how good your
adversarial loss is remember the this is
these length predictions are used to see
basically to see which of these tokens
the generator needs to produce the sound
for and how they're aligned so they have
an additional loss right here what they
do is they produce from the again they
go via the spectrograms within this
spectrogram prediction loss so they say
we discovered that adversarial feedback
is insufficient to learn alignment at
the start of training the aligner does
not produce an accurate alignment so the
information in the input token is
incorrectly temporarily distributed this
encourages the decoder to ignore the
aligner
output the unconditional discriminators
provide no useful signal to correct this
oh yeah I should have mentioned this the
discriminators here since you don't know
you don't know which tokens you should
produce the discriminators are
unconditional they don't know which text
is produced you don't give them the
tokens you simply give them the sound
waves that's something I find
particularly interesting here now you of
course this wouldn't work in a like a
traditional again because you simply
have a data sample here and a data
sample right here but in this case you
of course have the corresponding sound
samples but still they are you know they
are cut down to a subsequence so you
don't know which texts you're producing
so you have to make the discriminators
unconditional and therefore they are
going to discriminate as we said between
potentially between two completely non
overlapping pieces of the sound wave
which of course doesn't help you and
then the aligner
can also not learn anything because
there is no learning signal because
everything just says this is not the
same okay
and that's what they say here we face a
different problem we do not have aligned
ground truth conditional discriminators
which they don't have need an aligner
module which cannot function correctly
at the start of training effectively
turning them into unconditional
discriminator so even if they were to
input the text it would still be the
wrong text because their aligner is
wrong at the beginning although it
should be possible in theory to drain
the discriminators aligner module
adversarially we find that this does not
work in practice and training gets stuck
so what do they do they say instead we
propose to guide learning by using it
and explicit prediction loss in the
spectrogram domain we minimize the l1
loss between the log scale male
spectrograms of the generator output and
the corresponding ground truth training
window this helps learning to take off
and renders conditional discriminators
unnecessary simplifying the model so
they take the they take the spectrogram
of the generator output and the
corresponding ground truth training
window and they simply calculate the l1
difference of these spectrograms now
this as I understand it this is
different from this is different from
because we said they also have a
discriminator on the spectrograms this
is different from that this is even in
addition to that so here somewhere we
had yeah this this was the discriminator
on the spectrograms and i think this is
even different so what they're doing is
they also the discriminator simply
decides do the spectrums look real or
fake does the spectrogram look real or
fake now they also take these spectra
grams and compare them with the l1 loss
so this is exactly what they said they
wouldn't do right here
now it's still the case right it's still
the case that they don't use
spectrograms as intermediate
representations but they now do have a
supervised loss on the spectrograms and
one of the motivations to do this end to
end is saying you know maybe these
auxiliary losses and supervised losses
they they sort of distract they're good
to guide the training but they sort of
distract and now they see okay maybe we
have to introduce this one right here in
order to make the training start because
this is a this is a real signal but
again you run into a problem namely if
you produce something with the generator
and so first of all this is not a
discriminator anymore
this is a true l1 loss so we potentially
run into this problem right of the of
the generator simply copying the input
because you always tell it what the
correct input is this is now a
supervised loss that we guide the
training with and what was I gonna say
yes so you take the generator output you
transform it into a spectrogram you take
the real output transform it into
spectrum compare the l1 loss now you
sort of run into the same problem in
that if these are completely not aligned
then this is not going to work but since
you have a supervised loss this it can
it gives you a much stronger learning
signal of what the generator should
produce so you're kind of counting at
the beginning of training you're
counting on sort of a reverse reverse
learning process in that the real the
real sound will go into a spectrogram
and the generator will go here and then
that learning signal will sort of travel
to make the generator produce more of
whatever the real sound is and that
almost like if you think that the
aligner is so bad that we have even
non-overlapping fragments
basically you teach the generator to
ignore the inputs that it gets from down
here that again
from its entire backbone you teach it to
sort of ignore all of that if if that
makes any sense it simply produces the
sound according to this supervised loss
now of course it doesn't ignore it it
still takes the features but it ignores
the this whole alignment thing and now
once the generator gets a better signal
of what it should produce that signal
can travel back to the aligner module to
this length estimation module and guide
that one to make better predictions
about the lengths okay so that's how you
at the beginning of training you sort of
rely on this path of learning to make to
initialize this module of the aligner
and then once these length predictors
are better then the the loss can travel
in its intended path where you forward
produce these align sound waves and then
these discriminators take over I don't
exactly know if they trade this off
during training or they simply set it to
a number such that it helps them at the
beginning but it's a it's a good idea
and it's a it's a good trick to
introduce here a a supervised portion to
make the beginning easier but of course
you'd run into the same problem as I
said II and that the fact that if you
have two spectrograms they don't
necessarily align again and here they
use this dynamic time warping loss now
this looks very very similar to the
aligner but it is something different
because now you have two the difference
here is you have two things that you
know should match right you have this
thing and you have this thing and they
both have the same amount of entries so
they both have ABCDE this has an a a b a
c a d and an e slot and this also has an
a a b a c a d and an e slot and you know
that you as
so here is something you assumed you
assumed at the beginning and the ends
match this is not true of course because
we could have completely unaligned but
they say in practice this works so you
assume that sort of at least a little
bit
these are aligned all right so they have
by the way there's so much to this paper
by the way they have an auxiliary loss
where the produced lengths all the
lengths that the this length prediction
module produces they I don't remember
where that is but they have an auxiliary
loss where all the lengths must add up
right here all the lengths that these
length predictor sprues must add up to
the total length of the sound which in
our case I guess is the two seconds okay
so that's how they if so really quickly
these length predictions will sort of at
least the least thing they can do is
they can all predict like L over N and
that will give you a sort of a rough
alignment such that it's it kind of
makes sense to do this dynamic time
warping to assume that the beginnings
and the ending is aligned all right so
we have two things we they have the same
amount of of slots we know the
beginnings and end the line or we assume
that how do we make it how do we find
out which slots align to which and this
is a dynamic programming they formulate
this as a dynamic programming problem
that you might you know from you might
know from from like these are often
taught in algorithms and data structure
courses and so on where you you can
figure out which of these aligns so if
you go a step here that means that you
go one step in each in each of the
sequences and then if you go a step here
that means only this one advances and
this one still corresponds to this one
right here and okay I formulate it wrong
at the beginning you don't have a B
dde I guess he would actually have all
of these slots and you would figure out
which ones correspond to which yeah
but I hope you recognize these sort of
problems where Andy here you align them
again so these are classic dynamic
programming alignment problems and they
align it like this and they simply say
the more that this path deviates from
the straight path the larger penalty we
give so they give a penalty with respect
to how much this path deviates so here
you can see how much the spectrogram of
the generated the generated sound aligns
with the spectrogram of the ground truth
and here is a penalty for each time that
the two spectrograms don't align
correctly they do this in a soft way so
they do every single possible path right
here and you can again do this using
dynamic programming and the entire catch
here is that the alignment must be
monotonic because no matter how long you
know or short these sequences are they
always follow one after another in both
of these spectrograms and both of these
sounds so that's why you can optimize it
in a way so overall the possible paths
that you can align them you weigh these
paths by their score that you give them
here and then you calculate the loss
across all these different paths and
that will give you that is sort of a
fuzzy loss so you don't compare the
spectrograms directly but you compare
them and you sort of forgive them for
not aligning too well but the more they
don't align you give a penalty and
that's how you sort of force the
generator again you force the generator
to produce things that are aligned you
produce produce these length predictions
that make these spectrograms closer to
each other so that's how you calculate
the spectrogram loss this is entirely
deterministic there's no learned weights
right
here okay cool last thing they say is
that they use this phony miser that's
these very beginning but they also
oblate that so in the results they do a
lot lot of ablation studies which I
don't want to go into right now I've
already shown you some they do a even I
think they do a human evaluation do they
do a human evaluation and how this might
have been in another paper but as you
have heard from the examples this sounds
extremely realistic I'll link the
website to these samples in the in in
the video description for sure so I
think we've gone over everything the
generator starts off with text puts that
into normalized text calculates hidden
features right here these hidden
features on one hand are used to predict
lengths of each of the tokens in the
sound and are also used to as an input
to the generator here now they can only
be used as an input to the generator if
the generator knows how to align them in
time and how to align them in time is
predicted from these predicted lengths
right here via this aligner algorithm
this is enough that the lengths are the
only thing that is predicted everything
then is deterministic the aligner is
simply a Gaussian kernel over the
predicted locations on the on the time
axis it is so the Gaussian kernel is to
make it to make this alignment a bit
fuzzy to make this prediction fuzzy you
perform a weighted sum with these
features and then the generator knows
where to put the feet where they put the
tokens finally the generator can up
sample the toketee now aligned tokens
into sound this goes into the
discriminator the discriminator is
actually five different discriminators
which try each try to discriminate the
original from the real sorry the
generated from the real at different
time scales
in addition to that you have a
discriminator on the spectrum
rams and you also have an l1 loss on
these spectrograms which helps
especially at the beginning of training
for the l1 loss of the spectrograms you
have to again compute an alignment but
you do this in a deterministic way by
this thing down here this dynamic time
warping where you simply assume that
they are aligned and forgive them for
not being aligned with a with a soft
penalty and not a hard hard zero score
all right
this was the paper again if you like
this leave a like a comment share it out
subscribe and have a good day bye bye